hi I'm Nick Gillespie for reason TV and
I'm very happy to be talking to Jerry
Cameron of leap Law Enforcement Against
Prohibition a leading anti prohibition
group Jerry tell me tell me about leap
when did it start and what is its
mission well leap started approximately
eight years ago and it's a group
originally of just law enforcement
officers that had been connected with
drug enforcement and they were law
enforcement that have had come to the
conclusion that what they were doing was
not only ineffectual it was
counterproductive so that the costs of
prohibition far away any of the benefits
well if there are any benefits because
I've come to believe and most of the
people in leap that actually you you you
get a net damage to society rather than
a benefit and just to be clear you're
high right now right oh yes absolutely I
thought so I'm getting a contact buzz
right now what how big is leap and what
where are your action points what are
what are you pressing on mostly well
we've got a group of about twelve
thousand or so now and what we
originally started doing was going out
to mainstream society and saying look we
have credibility we've been in the
business and we we don't have any reason
to be telling you this other that's the
truth but this is how much this thing's
costing and this is the consequences is
this a good deal so Jerry what is leaps
break down how much does the drug war
cost and how much damage doesn't do well
the drug war is costing us on balance
all total over 70 billion dollars a year
where what is that money spent on that's
been on enforcement that is spent on
equipment that's been on capital
spending on prisons or that's that's
been on
the judicial system is the total cost of
it okay and that's the wrong kind of
stimulus spending right yes it is it
actually is not putting anything
productive into society we did you have
a particular moment where you were like
you know what not only is the drug were
ineffective but I've got to speak out
about it what was what was that moment
for you well actually i wish i was at
heroic it was a gradual process to me
that it became ineffectual and then i
started sort of analyzing the damage and
reading stuff that the government didn't
give me and I became convinced that it
was just bad policy but I was actually
retired and at home and Jack cold the
executive director of lead call me at
home and said now that you're out of the
drug war what do you think and I told
him I thought it was just an absolute
failure at best and counterproductive at
worst and he said are you willing to say
that publicly and you're not alone I
mean there are a number of mostly
retired or former police chiefs of major
cities small towns everywhere that are
saying this well we got federal judges
we've got customs agents we've got norm
Stanford with a chief in Seattle
Washington we've got some real high
grade executives and people out of
judiciary Corrections enforcement all
saying the same thing why why if the
drug war if the people who are in the
front lines of the drug worm and you
guys were the foot soldiers in the drug
war you're against it why does it
continue to grow why does it continue to
keep metastasizing well one thing about
any bad government public policy as soon
as it's put into place that special
interests get a vested interest and now
you've got private prisons that are
lobbying from stricter enforcement for
minimum mandatories you've got over the
the people that are working probation
for the courts you've got law
enforcement we've gotten all of our toys
for three decades
out of the federal government for Drug
Enforcement wait you're telling me that
like a small-town Florida sheriff at a
small Florida town doesn't need a tank
or a armored carriage armored personnel
vehicle we have one yeah in my County
but I don't think we put it to any
productive use so far all right fair
enough how do you feel about Obama
President Obama during his presidential
campaign he said he was going to end
raids on legal medical marijuana
dispensaries in California and other
states that allow that Eric Holder
Attorney General said that there have
been a couple of rates since then is he
going to be good on drug policy bad on
drug policy or ugly on drug policy well
being a basic libertarian there's so
much he's doing that I don't agree with
but this this latest action from his
attorney general that says that we're
going to recognize state sovereign tree
when it comes to enforcing the drug laws
I think that's a very positive step and
I don't think that we're going to
experience with this administration so
the mindless member of the faith it's
evil and we're not going to talk about
it I think that the topic will be on the
table with this administration what is
your drug of choice balvenie 21 year old
scotch ugh that's good to know and who
is your who is your great intellectual
or political hero Thomas Jefferson and
Patrick Henry and we're either of them
drug users they use Maduro extensively
fair enough and hopefully that'll stay
legally yes other things go south thank
you very much Jerry Cameron of leap for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie